Speaker 1: I want to make a goal of mine publicly
known so that you can hold me to it.
You know, one of the best ways to actually
get something done is to tell other people
that you plan to do it.
And my goal is to stop explaining myself to
idiots.
Now you might say, Well, whoa, sir, that's
very aggressive language.
What do you mean?
In order to try to save myself from thousands
of horrible comments, tweets and emails, I
will often over explain things and give disclaimers.
And I really am only doing that to people
who are just nuts or our bad faith actors.
So like when I say, Hey guys, you know, in
the in the Russia Ukraine thing, Putin's the
aggressor.
But to be clear, I don't support American
imperialism.
I don't think the U.S. is a perfect actor
with an unblemished record of foreign foreign
relations.
I do not favor the U.S. sending troops to
Ukraine.
I do not think the U.S. should choose the
leaders in other countries.
And all of those disclaimers are really for
like five percent of my audience.
Now I wish it was like one percent or less,
but it is about five percent of the audience,
but it's a very loud five percent.
It's a very weaponized five percent.
But most of you know that I don't mean invade
Russia when I say Putin is being the aggressor
here.
And likewise, when I say, you know, I can't
support the former Chavez now Maduro regime
in Venezuela because they've raped and pillage
the country's resources for themselves while
spewing false populist rhetoric about how
they're going to help everybody.
And meanwhile, people can't even afford food,
which there are shortages of anyway.
I don't mean invade Venezuela.
I don't mean assassinate Maduro.
I don't mean that the U.S. should pick who
is the leader in Venezuela.
I only mean, I don't like Maduro. 95 percent
of you get that.
But the five percent that don't or refuse
to are really loud and really annoying.
But this isn't normal.
This isn't a normal way to talk about things,
and this is sadly a toxic reality of the internet.
This is kind of like how Twitter works in
social media.
All these platforms select and and highlight
reactionaries and outrageous responses to
content.
I'll give you kind of like a benign example.
I post a picture of myself having a cappuccino
at a coffee shop in Los Angeles the way I
did two months ago.
This was on Instagram, not Twitter.
99 percent of the people who see me with my
stupid cappuccino say nothing.
I never hear from 99 percent of the people
who see that picture.
One percent leave a comment.
90 percent of the comments are completely
normal.
Weather looks great.
Looks great.
Have fun yet whatever of the comments.
OK, so we're talking 10 percent of the one
percent the people who choose to comment of
those comments.
10 percent.
People go crazy.
David, you're traveling during a pandemic.
You're so irresponsible.
How dare you?
You know, people died of COVID today.
The other one.
You're not wearing a mask, David, sit.
You don't you don't care about other people.
You're so self-centered that you drink a cappuccino
with no mask and No.
Three.
Are you drinking cow's milk?
How were you not a vegan?
You're a terrible person.
It's not normal.
And social media really skews this because
most people see a guy with a coffee and they
move on with their day.
But the internet has created this almost defensive
status quo for posting anything.
And on my show, I'm in this defensive mode.
Whenever I comment on stuff, even though anybody
normal or acting in good faith realizes these
are not normal reactions and that I'm not
saying whatever the worst faith possible interpretation
of my words actually is.
So my new effort is going to be not to do
the disclaimers and the defensiveness when
I just give my opinion about things on the
show.
Because at the end of the day, not only is
it preposterous to cater to people who are,
quite frankly, nuts or bad faith actors.
It also won't stop them from saying the exact
same things.
And I've got an example for you.
Look at the comments on my recent Russia clips
in those videos.
I say Putin is the aggressor, but I'm not
an imperialist.
I don't want war.
I don't want U.S. troops there.
I don't want U.S. involvement beyond, you
know, if Naito as an organization, says, Well,
we're going to support Ukraine in some way.
I don't want the U.S. doing regime change,
and I look at the video and I see comments
like the ones I'm putting up on the screen
for you right now.
You're just repeating establishment talking
points and neocon lies.
David.
I'm not imperialist, but let's have war now.
I did the disclaimers and I still got the
comment.
Next comment.
You are an imperialist.
No, no, no.
I explained it.
Another comment.
Tulsi is a twisted grifter, but you're brazenly
lying.
Warmongering imperialist trash, David.
I'm going to do my best because either way,
they're going to say that stuff.
So at the end of the day, I don't do the show
for that crazy five percent.
I'm doing the show for the good faith, 95
percent.
So the other five percent can, quite frankly,
you know, go go to wherever.
Hold me to it.
Keep me honest.
OK, I appreciate that.